is that a big red flag if
um you've got a substantial amount of
wealth and assets and she refuses to
sign a prenup
it is a big red flag um because she
doesn't
if she if she rejects a prenup out of
hand without even knowing the terms
um yeah i mean there are prenups where
guys have
agreed to give her over seven figures
but it's limited to that uh if he's
worth a lot more
he has a family business that he's
running and he wants to keep that
separate
so that's a good segue into what you
need to think about
before you see a lawyer what is it that
you're trying to protect you have kids
from an earlier marriage
so if you die uh you know that they're
not disinherited by the new wife
do you have a family business uh do you
have other assets that you're bringing
into the marriage
that you don't want calculated into the
marital estate
let's say you own real estate and you
had all of this real estate before you
got married
or a business you know everything that
happens
during the marriage stays in the
marriage generally so without a prenup
all of the increase in value
of that real estate over 10 years or
longer however long you're married
is a marital asset unless you have a
prenup which excludes all of that
uh increase in value so that's a good
mechanism and if somebody doesn't want
to sign that
after you've busted your rear end to uh
collect this real estate portfolio you
might want to ask why not
i mean that's not fair often the um
the pushback from women seems to come
from
some sound bite or some narrative along
the line of
uh well if we sign that then we're
really
like we're really not in love or we're
setting the marriage up to fail if we do
that
that's that's usually some version of
this or that like
how how would you recommend a client uh
respond to something like that
it's just a pragmatic practical thing
it will also save uh a ton of costs
and wear and tear on both of them not to
have to litigate it
but i don't buy that disney-esque oh
love you're my one
we're gonna be together till death do us
part first
it says that in the vows yeah i mean
that's
that's crazy uh statistically it is
isn't it yeah
would you jump out of an airplane if
there was a 50 plus chance that the
parachute wouldn't open
i don't think so no but women every day
convince men to get married without a
prenup
well come on guys you hold that frame
uh you you don't have to be a jerk about
it
and you don't have to say well every
penny i make during the course of this
marriage even if we have 10 kids
is going to be mine if you decide to
leave me
but you have every right to step up and
say
you know what it makes good sense
for me to do this and you you're not
looking to give her nothing
um i honestly i've had women who are the
moneyed spouse
and they stand firm no wedding until
this is done to
amazing my that works and these are
very very beautiful attractive women
who have worked hard and earned it
some earned some inherited whatever
they didn't care how long it took uh to
nail the final version down and then
have it properly executed so it's it
just makes good sense so
there's thing there's mechanisms in
place that you can put in a prenup like
a sunset clause where if you're married
for a certain number of years
the prenup could go away but
everything's negotiable between two
adults in most jurisdictions the courts
can't step in and modify it
or set it aside so
long story short you have to know what
jurisdiction are in what the law says
and have it properly drafted and
executed
you